welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
boss and this is a breakdown of the
falcon the winter soldier episode 2
the star spangled man in which nearly
every avenger gets a mention
even avengers the government didn't want
us to know about i'm going to break down
this episode for all the interesting
details that you might have missed
and special thanks today's sponsor
wondershare filmora10
stick around to hear how you can use
filmora 10 to make your own video
content
okay so last episode i pointed out how
the opening close-ups of sam irony in
that black suit gave us some major
funeral vibes as sam did hope to
entomb cap's shield in the museum and
the opening image of this episode used
his wardrobe similarly with the close-up
of that zipper going down like a body
bag opening up to reveal a corpse inside
which metaphorically it is kind of the
corpse of steve rogers legacy
sam wanted to lay it to rest john walker
is kind of frankensteining it back to
life
in quite an unnatural way this whole
locker room scene paints a sympathetic
picture of walker
everybody in the world expects me
to be something and i don't want to fail
them
good morning america yeah yeah i get you
john good morning america can be quite a
nerve-wracking thing to do
also does gma being in the mcu now make
me mcu cannon by extension
walker's buddy here is lamar hoskins aka
battle star so in the comics john walker
started as super patriot
kind of an [ __ ] replacement cap and
he's accompanied by bold urban commandos
or
buckies including hotskins walker ends
up getting the cap title he goes crazy
kills a bunch of people and eventually
the government makes him u.s
agent whose uniform actually looks a lot
like what walker wears here
this episode makes it seem like they
could have decent intentions despite
clues pointing otherwise two weeks ago
we're prepping the team for a special
ops mission and chile and now this
a lot of handshakes a lot of suits a lot
of
speeches and senator meetings now
remember bucky just busted
senator atwood former hydro operative
which seemed like a one-off thing except
the end credits included a missible
headline
about senator atwood pushing for border
enforcement i don't know maybe this
senator was pushing walker to round up
border crossers and then that mission in
chile the last time we saw a special ops
team in south america
it was led by a super soldier sent by
thaddeus ross
who also might be behind all of this his
name appeared in the end credits with a
mention of
enhanced humans act now hoskins
mentioned the star-spangled man with the
plan which is this episode's title
and the marching band music is that same
star spangled man with a plan
from cap's warbonne store in the first
cap film
yeah this is all a modern version of
that same original cat publicity tour
down to signing collectibles
custer's grove high school custer's
grove is the hometown of john walker in
the comics it's also where the extremist
group the watchdogs try to kill walker
and then end up getting his parents
killed
making him go berserk the gma
interviewer says the government did a
study of your body at mit
and you tested off the charts in every
measurable category
speed endurance intelligence look here's
the thing i'm not
tony stark i'm not dr banner then we see
shots of him with a punching bag
recalling cap with a punching bag and
avengers
and then footage of him with the shield
a shield that he would have just gotten
meaning his coordination must be
abnormally good that might actually be
why walker cuts
her off when she is talking about his
freaky physiology
i think he and hoskins might have
already been given super soldier serum
interesting how walker's suit design
positions the a
with wings logo so that it bleeds over
onto the shoulder strap so that the look
is only complete if he is suited up
perfectly
unlike steve rogers who was able to rip
his logo off his shoulder and still
function in the suit
this guy is a manufactured hero
restrained by the government he has to
represent with this iconography bucky
and sam talk about the big three
i have a feeling they might be a part of
the big three what big three
the big three white big three androids
aliens and wizards
that's not a thing that's definitely no
it's not androids for ultron aliens for
thanos and his army wizards presumably
for loki i mean sam wasn't part of the
avengers yet but remember loki
learned his sorcery from friega and
asgardian witch also this does take
place
five months after wandavision sam could
be also referencing the threat of the
witches of west view which is gonna come
back to the mcu in multiverse madness
then bucky says so who are you fighting
now gandalf
how do you know about gandalf i read the
hobbit in 1937 when it first came out
yeah bucky just checked him with uh
i understood that reference he's such a
nerd i love it and then after staring
contest on the plane they argue
enjoy your ride buck no you can't call
me that why not that's what steve called
you steve knew me longer and steve had a
plan
what is it
only cat can call him buck just like
scott lang with cap only friends are in
the one syllable club now being the man
with the plan is really the key here
the titular song in this episode is that
captain america was the star spangled
man
with the plan on the avengers cap was
really the one who called the shots he
always had the plan so really the
conflict among these four
cap successors is as much over who has
the best plan
as it is is whoever has the shield sam's
plan here is kind of what cap did in
captain america winter soldier just dive
out of the plane without a shoot i love
how bucky's like yeah yeah i can do it
but then he definitely gets nervous
about it and falls pretty hilariously
as they snoop on the flag smasher sam
says little time in wakanda and you come
out white panther
it's actually white wolf huh yeah
remember after civil war bucky rested in
wakanda
and in black panther local wakandan kids
nicknamed him the
white wolf white wolf aka hunter is a
separate character in the comics leading
the wakandan secret police
bucky owns up to this title despite not
really gearing up
until the battle of wakanda in infinity
war so in what other ways did he
assist shuri in t'challa to earn this
title flag's master carly morgenthau
is played by aaron kellerman the cloud
writer in this nest in solo
she gets her name from the character
flag smasher carl morgenthau in the
comics
and she is strong she breaks red wing
but if you think about it this actually
does
sam a favor since he finds out after
this that the government had hacked into
that drone to spy
on all of his movements that's why it
was glitchy before and that's probably
where they heard the phrase the big
three now the truck license plates are
mk a5012 and 2011 ekh now 2011 ekh is
actually the same tag number as the one
on wanda maximoff's rental in one of
mission episode 8 5012 might refer to an
alt
marvel comics universe where cap is gone
not sure about that one but then cap
walker drops in
yeah the composer henry jackman worked
in a light motif to captain america's
theme it sounds like cap's promise from
civil war now bucky has to
dodge the shield when walker throws it
it looks like walker did not care if he
was gonna hit bucky in the face
but later in this fight bucky catches
the shield with his normal hand not his
vibranium one and then hands it back to
walker
and not to his dramatic catch and winter
soldier and kind of a way of saying hey
watch where you throw that thing cap
but before we continue are you looking
for an easy to use video editing
software well today's sponsor
wondershare filmora is here to help
wondershare filmora 10
is perfect for both beginners and
experienced video editors it has tons of
royalty-free music and preset templates
like text filters and animated stickers
you can make a quality video in under 10
minutes i like how it's really easy to
use it's got all the bells and whistles
that our editors need but you can also
add filters and effects just as easy as
you can on instagram check it out i've
now added
glitch lines and turn this into some
like found footage that will definitely
be the last thing you see before you die
so maura is running a campaign with the
hashtag
travel anywhere in march use household
items or filmora effects to create a
video
imagining you are traveling to somewhere
exotic
click the link in the description to see
how to participate and what kind of
prizes you can win
and if you want to remove the watermark
on the free version comment with what
you think of tomorrow with the hashtag
createwithfilmora filmora will pick a
lucky winner to give away a one-year
free license so if you want to get into
content creation but don't know how to
start download wondershare film or a 10
by clicking the link in the description
below to try it for free
there's a moment where walker pulls out
his gun and shoots a flag smasher now i
know cap used a gun in world war ii and
even sam here uses red wing to fire on
him but it is just
weird to see captain america in the
modern era the mcu using a firearm on
people
sam and bucky conclude these flag
smashers must be super soldiers which
seems to come as news to the other guys
and we're pretty sure it's one of the
big three
so aliens androids are wizards there's
no such thing as wizards all right then
it's aliens or androids or super
soldiers
super soldiers for real yeah wow
ah that look so either walker and
hoskins are really dim
or they know full well that the flag
smashers are enhanced super soldiers
because
these two came from the same enhancement
program that power broker the flag
smashers are ripping off
could be the power broker who enhanced
walker and hoskins in the comics
and interestingly later joaquin torres
turning him into the next falcon
walker says he jumped on a grenade
before like cat but walker says he used
a reinforced helmet see his training is
a manufactured replica of the real thing
that steve went through because steve
jumped on that grenade assuming he would
die they bring up the grc
global repatriation council an agency
that manages resources for returning
blip refugees
this could be what thaddeus ross now
heads up because here he could use this
new team of super soldiers to keep the
peace
internationally because we know ross has
been trying to build a team like that
for a long time
back to the early days of the incredible
hulk and then maybe these flag smashers
could have been
past super soldiers who escaped when the
blip happened and stalled ross's plans
it's all connected they provide the
resources we keep it stable violent
revolutionaries aren't usually good for
anyone's cause you usually say about the
people with the resources
sounds like sam's drinking that flag
smasher kool-aid his bank loan denial
reminded him
resources are not fairly distributed and
then walker says
i'm just trying to be the best captain
america
i can be i'll marry us army be all that
you can
be but then he blows it it'd be a whole
lot easier
if i had cavs wingmen on my side
it's always that last line by belittling
sam is merely cap's wingman he totally
misunderstands the partnership between
sam and cap we also learned that sharon
carter who's also gonna be returning
this show was like the rest of them
labeled a criminal for stealing their
gear in civil war and then sam meets
this kid
hey it's black falcon it's just falcon
kid
my daddy told me it's black falcon
because i'm
black and i'm the falcon well
technically
so are you like black kid yes comics
have a history of using characters race
in their name
like black goliath which was later
changed to just goliath but that this
kid's dad
called him black falcon reflects that
many in this society
are clearly not colorblind which is
something they find later with this
awful encounter with the cops so isaiah
bradley he was the black captain america
introduced in 2003
his history was erased he was one of the
300 black test subjects which we get a
hint at in the end credits
and most of those test subjects died it
was really based on the way the
government
in real life gave black men syphilis in
the tuskegee experiments
really [ __ ] up now in the comics
isaiah's grandson is elijah bradley who
becomes a young avenger patriot and the
kid who answers the door is labeled in
the credits as eli bradley elijah
richardson and notice his reaction when
isaiah snaps
i'm not gonna talk about it anymore
yeah in the young adventures comics
eli's powers are later revealed to just
be him juicing up with a mutant growth
hormone he actually does not have
natural powers so here this might be him
wishing he had that kind of strength
isaiah wedges that tin in the wooden
frame it's actually similar to how sam
will
later wedge the shield into the wood of
a tree it's kind of like for these guys
the legacy of cap doesn't allow them to
bounce off obstacles like teflon they
just get stuck in it
isaiah reveals the awful history of how
the government treated him you know what
they did
to me for being a hero they put my ass
in jail for 30 years
people running tests
taking my blood coming into my cell
even your people weren't done with me
and by bucky's people he meant
hydra meaning hydra might have derived
their own super soldier serum cocktail
from
isaiah's blood after they get arrested
walker gets bucky out
bucky's not gonna be following a strict
schedule any longer we haven't finished
our work who authorizes
um the biggest douche of balmor as when
he threw that shield at bucky's head he
does not care about bucky's well-being
only how he can use him and after
leaving therapy bucky asks dr raynor
what was rule number two again
don't hurt anyone yeah bucky needed this
reminder as he goes off to face zemo
another name on his men's list whom i'm
sure he wants to hurt very badly the
flag smasher's gotta scramble how much
time do we have
none it's the power brokers man yeah we
saw the name power broker in the
end credits power broker is watching and
again i think he is linked to that same
whole history of human enhancement that
walker and hoskins and thaddeus ross
could be involved in
we end the episode in this german prison
facility that zemo was left in
and he is in cell 2187 which is a nod to
star wars cell 2187 was where princess
leia was kept on the death star
in itself was a nod to the short film
2187 that inspired george lucas to make
thx 1138 and star wars keeps bringing
this number back like later finn's
designation was fn2187 mozart's requiem
plays and then we see the chess set
which actually kind of echoes magneto's
imprisonment in the x-men movies but
like that super villain this guy i don't
think will be in prison for much longer
hey to celebrate the series we have our
new latest obsession shirt anarchy
assembled you can get this at
newarkstartsmerch.com follow me on
instagram and twitter ideavos follow new
rockstars and subscribe to rockstars
here on youtube for deep dives into
everything marvel thanks for watching
[Music]
you